yeah let's get see these auditions man i
want to see who's ready for this
my name is alex hernandez and here's
five reasons of why i should be in the
culture corner one i'm not a predator
two
i'm not a racist three i'm mexican as
[ __ ] bro
four i'm extremely reliable i have my
own car and
five i'm a g said come on nick watch out
i got that brett favre
hitter holmes i'm also an editor and i
have a youtube channel with over ten
thousand subscribers to show for it
which means that i can edit for you guys
make clips and things of that nature i'm
also a big fan of each and every single
one of you and i respect
the hell out of all of you too and
thanks to all of you for making us laugh
oh and did i mention that i'm fluent in
spanish
anyways that's my time i'm alex a
mexican and i need a
beer yo
all right i'm not mad at him now is he
local is he in l.a
if he's a cheese head that's a little
weird to be a cheesehead in l.a yeah
and it's queso de cabeza actually i
think he said uh
in spanish uh theo and brenda are muy
caliente
uh i prefer fimales
yourself keep like your shirt says
otherwise that seems more like a
go ahead and brennan prefers tamales
your friend joe exotic says otherwise
dude please
well donald trump please pardon joe i
agree before you leave man get that man
out of prison
so we get [ __ ] tiger king 2 up in
this [ __ ] i need something to watch
please
um look i like this guy's attitude some
of the stuff that he loved all of us
that sounds hard to believe sometimes
when people say like just group love
like that but
um i did like his attitude he only has
like a minute or something to really get
his point across
i love the fact also that he is willing
to work after he gets off of the
clocktowel
with editing yeah yeah that was more of
a control room audition
i think than culture he seemed good at
it that was the best submission we've
had as far as quality and editing
by far the best yeah that's pretty good
yeah i wonder where he lives that now
control he did seem like control room
editor
maybe maybe there's something there yeah
i actually did find it he's from san
diego
so okay okay he can move and look if
he's really a hundred percent mexican
dude he'll keep heading this way anyway
yeah he's gonna be up here anyway yeah
some coconuts uh let's see what these
guys say
ian what's up king this thing my name is
ian callahan and this is why i should be
in the culture we got a chain for
the white boy i live in l.a right on
pico robertson right next to all of the
hebrew
uh or orthodox jew however you want to
call it so that's okay
i am a convicted felon so we can talk
about that that is culture in itself
of your prison culture you're out
brother um
and let's not forget that i do have a
rap song called had to pull them titties
out i dropped when i was 18 years old
and it is an absolute banger and we have
some asian christmas dancers dancing in
it
and i will put the link in the
in this email um so you can check it out
nick but i think
it would be a great time and i'd love to
join gang gang buzz buzz culture culture
okay convicted felon usually that's
frowned upon but
we're uh equal employers here oh yeah
nick went to jail didn't you nick i have
never been to jail you've never been in
jail
nope that's surprising i wonder if we
didn't i wonder if we just put on the ig
do you think nick has been in jail or
not what people would vote
80 yeah i think it'd be pretty high i'll
put it up i'm trying to find this guy's
email
uh see if he's do we want to watch uh i
would love to see it yeah we'll drop
them titties out here yeah
drop them titties sounds like a banger
don't say banger though because we've
never heard of it though you know
i bet brendan's in it weren't you in
that nelly video brendan what were you
in
uh m c hammer so crazy don't disrespect
me nelly come on
emcee hammer bro you were in uh what's
uh what's
with that chica's name bad barbie that's
right that was dope
this is uh had to pull them titties out
the music video young klepto
had to pull them to young klepto
looks like my dad
that's ravishing rick rude baby may he
rest in peace
i'm about to get my titties out
this video is kind of chatty yeah it's
been too long of an intro
yeah oh
bunch of cats
looks like they're performing this at a
local high school
oh yeah
this looks like one of those japanese
mental health facilities kinda
i've seen a lot of [ __ ] videos that
start like this
i haven't seen any of that okay i'm good
here
i have to pull them too thank you
jonathan what's the guy's name
what do we think of ian the convicted
felon
we've had some good submissions i'm not
mad at the banger and i'm at the title
pull them titties out but
i don't know we've had some good ones
man i don't
need another white person in here i
don't get sued
that's the tricky part these days
especially uh you know
and look i love what you did man i love
your work i love the fact you've been in
jail
you know you made it out i like that you
like titties we could use another
straight male in here
yeah we probably could man i i like the
costumed viets
you know that's one of my favorite thing
bro it's easy to get some asians but
also to dress them up
um what else man i like your style i
think maybe check back with us in a
month
that's fair when he's off parole yeah oh
who's this baddie though
hey brandon what's up theo it is abby
from san francisco
i am submitting to be in your guys's
culture corner
um after corvette hit i moved back down
to la
and um i thought i could bring my
ashkenazi schnazzy
to your guy's studio and finally get a
juice point of view
on the king and the sting um theo that
hitter of a nose was fooling us for a
little bit
but i think the viewers are catching on
and for the sanctity
of your guys's podcast running out of
hollywood
um i think it's about time you guys get
a chosen one on the show
and uh sorry but usually when you get us
involved good things do happen
just saying um i'm also born and raised
in the mecca of all things woken dope
so in today's society um i think it's
good for me to be well
versed in nancy pelosi's satanic bible
and uh governor newsom spark notes on
how to ruin a society
fortunately they run the district that i
call home and um part of the reason why
our comedy scene is completely dead
but that's okay i'm submitting to be
on your guys's show and if you guys want
me there theo just like feather your
mullet and brandon click your off white
collabs three times
i'll be there for you boys okay um gang
gang shabbat shalom my jews
amen player thank you miss she called it
this is the
new off-white collab i like this young
lady
i like this young lady listen she looks
like halsey
all right she looks a little bit like
halsey and i think she could be a good
addition
and i think her and theo have the exact
same nose
okay i think she looks like theo's
sister and i think she'd be a great
addition to the culture corner let's get
joey up here theo
first of all brendan i just got my
sister a nice gold chain
that i gave to her at a waffle house the
other night where the cook had just quit
when we got there
and we didn't know and we ordered and
the lady there she's like can't you
[ __ ] see we don't have a cook
no [ __ ] okay no [ __ ] it's our goddamn
chicken can't see that
yeah cannot see that that's fine but
[ __ ] you should put a sign on the
door
okay so anyway
quite a time over there at the baton
rouge uh
waffle does she not look like halsey
halsey is also jewish though burning so
i think you're just you're just holsie's
also half black
do you know that her dad is beautifying
um we've got another
submission i like the jew girl though
for the record i like the jugra i think
it should be a fun addition
and i clap my heels three times and i
got new off-whites on oh
who's this little is that halsey
hey cats family alicia here merry
christmas
i am submitting a video today to come
and hang out with you guys in the
culture corner i would love to come
and be a part of the culture corner i do
live in
southern california area um i submitted
a video
a while ago for what better dad episode
18
and i am on there so you can check me
out there
um that's it i hope you all are doing
well happy new year
gang gang buzz buzz culture culture love
y'all buzz buzz young queen
the thing is is you're you she's so
friendly
if her and chappelle had a kid the world
would be right they're just too
friendly you know
but she's also and within one minute
that's the thing what kind of what side
of yourself do you show you know what
i'm saying
if you have one minute to show people
something do you show them
nine of your fingers or they you're
missing a finger you show that you miss
a finger off the bat son you come with
that heat
like that jew girl came with the heat
off the bat cracking some
jokes some pelosi jokes some new some
jokes
yeah it's hard to know what to
like if there's any real there's no real
criteria she made fun of your nose which
i liked
yeah well that's easy to do uh this is
but look yeah both these ladies i think
i mean look this is the first i'm seeing
in the video
so i think we'll have to think about it
here's the other thing too we could
rotate
random guess until we find one that fits
if there's chemistry
you can rotate through them yeah the
audition tape's just step one yeah
that's just step one we bring you in
cool thanks for trying out
bringing another one thanks for trying
then maybe sometime next year we make a
final decision
next year brendan
like mid next year mid-2021
mid mid next year these people could go
on with their lives they could be
married
yeah maybe i don't think it means a year
from now i mean i think it means a
couple days
yeah exactly thursday's next year woogie
uh okay here is hands down
you look the wrong way oh sorry it's
wigardo
here's hands down the weirdest uh one
we've received so far
[Music]
that's me on the left
now you see these hands can also make
eye babies
[Music]
so if you guys would have loved piano
it'd be greatly appreciated
you guys need some help listen
betterhelp.com promo code cats
everybody needs help
look at that first of all young man
thank you very much for sending that in
bro that's a beautiful piece of art i
think
yeah you full [ __ ] and you're scared
listen i'm gonna call what it is that
thing was creepy bro
maybe maybe resend something in that we
can use you know
listen i don't want no problems i don't
want no problem
don't pull up my house in the rv with
explosives i want no problems
brendan no problem shove over there i
want the [ __ ] smoke white boy
okay or whatever that guy might have
been semi-white
i was like i say bring it bro bring it
over here king of the sink studios
bring it out here to calabasas bring it
to freaking bee charlotte's house
and let's do this [ __ ] bro
bring your guns bring your anthrax let's
go we can get saucy if you want broth
roll up these sleeves
is that it nick that's it that was fun i
thought again i think that girl's the
best submission
i think the ladies have taken the lead i
think yes
but i look forward to figuring that out
and thinking about it a little bit
[Music]
it's more king of nice games